so how many Cumberland sister's hope you
guys were to show before the video
starts just want to make one thing very
clear so people know where to give what
the top for burial funds launchcode calm
15 barrows is for the organization took
care of his body when we had nowhere to
go so if you guys want to give to all
that you can
he says body the easiest burial is fully
covered that's just to help further
reverts or other people who didn't have
family members so donate to that
generously the one in the middle for
easiest family is for his daughter and
his wife and we're raising funds for
their family the one at the bottom is
for agony a project in Ghana which I
spoke with either specifically and you
can see that in the video I shot as you
watch it so I wanna make that very very
clear show us so you guys know why to
give please watch the video may Allah
bless you guys and please keep hissing
it was a Salam alaikum one who deliver
care to above the sisters and their
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
for those of you know most people would
know and for those who do not know
ISA has passed away
may I love mercy on him I'm just gonna
tell you guys how it all folded this
video was done for a reason we're gonna
raise funds for a variety of things
which you guys I'm sure more than
willing to do that in sha Allah we're
gonna explain everything how he passed
away I've been told how he unfolded
where I was who contacted me all of them
gonna go through but before I do that
bond sisters oh you guys to know that
inshallah
Muslim Eden care and Muslim burial fund
have made our life so much so easier
well lucky when this all unfolded was
you've been here very soon and how this
happened I'm Allah he his father-in-law
and myself and his wife would in like
that we just in we didn't know what to
do you're gonna find out why but please
the first thing I want to mention is
please give sadaqa to this organization
they helped bury Muslim specially
Reavers who do not have any family any
family members at all and so panel they
have helped us immediately so please
please please I ask you the first thing
to give is inshallah whatever little you
want to I know you want to give sadaqa
try before
Esau and his family and his daughters
you're gonna come to later inshallah but
please they have done an amazing job but
you're gonna find out soon the link is
here make sure you give to that and yeah
so I'm gonna get straight into inshallah
bonuses in foster I want to play sauce
of handouts are the most merciful the
most trust or praise His glory
ingratitude belong to him last night I
was a team on channel up Indian live
appears for them in Ramadan throughout
as upon Allah a week before he didn't
care who deal with his burials but in
contact me and I did a live appeal for
them and I just you know live appeal and
I'm gonna raise some funds to help bury
Muslims of a time from the virus and so
yeah so that's how I knew of them anyway
send us mail other of allah subhanaw
taala saleh they were the first people
are turned to you so yesterday i was
doing a live appeal with film charity
doing works in Africa in Malawi raising
four orphans and you guys know my wife
refused to watch it you know I tried to
make jobs keep the hyper life joking
around messing around making jokes you
know all that kind of stuff and usually
I shouldn't check out my phone on a live
appeal but I check it every now and then
you know itseif
you know my wife is message or something
like that and these guys guys can as you
guys can see on the screen I got a quote
from Esau so I've saved them as ISA SC
speakers corner
and before okay so I'm unlucky for
always I can't answer and it was give me
kind of sitting like why would he call
like at this time you know why would he
call fines of men of understanding
and that's exactly all whether that was
bloody very something serious what like
I checked my phone brother I know I just
passed away so I'm I'm gonna go upon
allah subhanallah brothers and sisters
make dua for those upon a lot of a
savanna worth passed away may Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala have mercy upon all
our dead yaro Bilal I mean found a bit
strange but for anyway so I went I went
to my snapchat I mean I went to my
what's up no more what's up I saw the
message that you guys can see on the
screen ball and sisters and wallah he I
couldn't believe what I read and he said
Salaam alaikum Ali could you contact me
please and I think it's probably
probably so maybe it's concerning
brother Esau so when I read that first
finger for maybe I mean the accident
maybe something that happened
and the following message was I'm his
father-in-law and he has passed away and
why I was in shock I couldn't believe
why I could not believe it
I couldn't believe it when why he always
like know how
my voice is a job like why is this I
leave I left a life appeal which you
guys can see if I can get the footage
you probably see it I left him I was
absolutely shocked I went and I sat down
and I wrangled I didn't know what to do
III was in shock I rang the would
explained it to him and you know he
start crying stop crying together and he
was telling me broke three hours ago
three hours ago he was on faith Facebook
Instagram he was liking my post how how
did he do you mean he died I said I
think I don't know if he's not supposed
to hours ago it must be a sudden death
so obviously we both were like very bit
like was upon I was crying on the phone
together with him because he was
destroyed you know like I know and the
world is distraught and he's a prophet
because we've brother Esau alive when I
used to go speakers corner
what line one of the things I used to
look forward to you know like eating
with them just chillin with him what
lying I just loved every tongue will
speak his corner sometimes all the
brothers will go to a specific
restaurant and sometimes I'll just say
look bro let's just do our own thing you
know the scott-heron towards now this
restaurant we loved and we love to eat
you know that's how we had together we
just love the different restaurants
wallahi before this lockdown happened
before this lockdown happened
subhanAllah all I complete for you guys
for the logs I'm happy we met I said to
him because we me and him we are
suffering to come we will travel to the
other side of the city just to go eat
new restaurants whenever I discovered a
new dish are you hopeful this is so
banging out what I and I would love for
you and doubt would come bro let's try
this was like little missions I would go
on we would come from all day from South
London me from North London we'll go all
the way to East to an Afghani restaurant
E together and like handle I just
comment on the food this is amazing bro
you know he would come do missions just
to go eat while I I love this company so
much while I I cannot describe to you
guys how beautiful this brother was he
smiling light up the place your him
had that his character what like his HOF
speech with everyone how beautiful he
was while lying I couldn't I was going
through some video footages couple of
days ago and and I was I was thinking
wow a news of me him and out and I was
at bra like all finger Thomas I missed
out so much I can't wait for this virus
to be over two days ago I was looking at
that footage brothers and sisters two
days ago and subhanAllah
anyways so I went back up I spoke to his
father-in-law his father-in-law said he
went out shopping
he went out shopping to get some stuff
for his toreador two years old two or
three years old for his wife he went out
to their shopping and he wasn't feeling
well you know his house was on the third
floor so he told his wife that you know
I think he could he wasn't able to go up
upstairs for some reason some say might
be the virus they're saying my god I
don't know I don't know they saying it
might be the viruses feel swelling he
had some issues breathing more than
usual that he usually has and his wife
had to come downstairs and help him up
and she took him inside and he collapsed
and she he died in her arms and
subhanAllah
so paralyzed as Anthony's it's an odd
night last 10 nights EST was at last 10
nights his father-in-law Corden and he
said the ambulance have come and they've
left the body there but you mean that
you've left the body hose here the
bodies here they've put it in bags and
they've just left it this in the house
he goes I'm right in front of it nose up
how but you how how are they sleep in
the body there is it brother Ali I don't
know so the first thing that came to my
mind was to read to call eating care
because that's the only one I know it'll
clear Muslim burial foundation laughing
that's what their code and why I called
them and I was gonna call them myself I
was gonna head there myself and they
said look if it's a virus you shouldn't
go there you shouldn't go there and I
said okay and they said we're gonna get
someone what like immediately within one
hour after fajr of the brothers prayed
they came to pick up the body can you
imagine the person who is passed away
they just there nobody's taking tablets
just left it there saying that it may be
in a heart failure his heart couldn't
cope with it there was a clotting as
long as we don't know we don't know so
what I do know bones sisters that's a
pan on the world
what a beautiful so you may have yeah it
was he saw a lot he with everyone you
know whenever we went to eat you adapt
your character what an amazing well I
I'm I'm gonna miss so much the fact that
were like it's just gonna be this void
in my life you know like you as a Bravo
you know stuff like you know the CIA
would give me you would hear me out
you know even when it was such a
beautiful buffer that so final even when
certain controversies having certain
issues when I was raising funds for debt
mail have mercy on him you know he would
come and say to me actually you know you
know
when you go to Ghana etc you know you
take pictures you know with these kids
you know is there a specific reason you
have to have them on there and what like
he would never had negative assumptions
he never seemed uh why are you doing
this done he would come and say okay you
know what's the reason I was a problem
this is the reason we do and wallahi are
speaking of dawood he mentioned these
two days ago to another brother that
they were having a discussion about this
very much and he said oh I lead our
explained why they have to use the kids
etc because otherwise people don't give
and sadly that's his case form sisters
if we don't show you the reality and
what's going on they don't give and I
can remember when this whole situations
going he said to me bro when I explained
this him how the work the charity etc
sector you know how things work and how
we fundraise he said to me cannot convey
the gone because he was Ghani in himself
which comes to our said the kajari that
were gonna do Brahma sisters and I'm
gonna play some audio recordings of him
and a video i'm gonna play inshallah but
had a discussion we had a beautiful
discussion and so para look what he says
in this video we're gonna come to that
but in this in the video he in sorry
when i had the discussion with him about
the car and he said I want to come with
you and I was arranging for him to come
with me to Ghana to see the project for
himself and get on board cause he wanted
to immerse his home country Ghana
he's gone in and one why because he said
that we have a project that we've been
working on over half we've raised the
funds were in twenty five thousand
pounds
it's a project called the life village
this is someone with me and Mohammadi
job when you can see from the video
footages and our aim was dead surround
the villages to build a Masjid a school
a playground and also a mechanical bull
water well I've got the name what the
name and the whole project cost fifty
five thousand pounds BOM sisters we
spoke with the family I spoke with his
wife I spoke with his father-in-law
they give it gave us the coop coop got
the videos to go ahead
sadaqa Jerry on his behalf and Charla
and that's exactly what we need to do
BOM sisters were raising for three
things number one funds for his wife and
his daughter number two sabotage area in
Ghana where he personally told me
himself that he would want
it would want to get involved in
Charlotte bond sisters that's what we're
gonna do in I'm gonna play a video last
time I met with him when we met to go to
Somali restaurant in Tottenham and so
peril he traveled all the way and you'll
see here look so basic so this is where
this was 1950 March yeah so not even
much about two months ago so I said let
me confirm here cuz I got boxing at
eight
I said okay bro let me know what you see
in sure we're gonna hit the spot after
boxing is that long I was caught this
afghani restaurant
he said I'm finished work now so they
left so you let me know I said lucky
maybe tomorrow I'm in some traffic Dom
Mitchum there's a matching coat tomorrow
inshallah then so it always me up to go
eating
I say okay let me know he said I wish I
finished work at 5:00 so I'll holler at
you then should I tell doubled I said
okay then yes we can but his god you
know he's not well so I said I fear for
him by calling him because that was not
where I was going through some health
problems so because of where Easton was
time if I didn't want to put him at risk
I said Cole let me know inshaallah I'll
leave him out well suggested shows at
home okay a holler if you want to come
he said yeah definitely come where you
are now I finished working
[Music]
Spinola
it's power
- no your friend has died and you know
to hear his voice was so unreal
for those no they know and he was
speaking to him like he's alive he's not
here anymore
he's not here anymore why he how beloved
he was it must have been to Allah for
Allah to take him on an odd night 21st
night yesterday in Ramadan the last 10
nights so we carried on speaking and I
was telling him you know send me on
location span I was even just showing
him how you know so I said to him okay
and then he sent me a location to see
where is that was gonna go to Somali
restaurant brother's restaurant then
this was in him when we got there
the integration of their love they have
some fresh laminar part in surah taha I
run down to shipping as thoughts even
shortly get some some money and some
some loss rate bits now everything is
gone
so that was the last day
me and him we went to a Somali
restaurant together
and we a wallahi we went all the way
there because you know I'm not much both
together with love food
you know how was that bro you need to
try this sport subhanAllah and he came
with me we ate together and I remember
that restaurant I was talking about the
virus how it's a sign from allah
subhanaw taala
and subhanAllah and was just eating
together handle I did a few lost be
shopping for his family and yeah
subhanAllah and now he's not here
and this is a video I want to play this
video for you guys born sisters and this
is a video of him look at what he says
this was last year November no he says
the other accident was talking about
some was a hide accident as well and he
had a car accident where he hit a car on
his bike look what he says
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
lots of people stop nurses brokers
myself okay everything's connected
no breakages it was literally just the
proofs side are swollen still at the
moment yeah lots of people helps you
know what really gets to me the fact I'm
never gonna have a sit-down with the
beginner I'm never gonna have a
heart-to-heart with them again
inshallah I was the shall I follow unite
us in Jenna definitely he's one person I
would love to spend hours just sitting
and listening to him his core and yeah I
need his explanations yeah he's no it
was knowledgeable well he was very
knowledgeable and he would explain
things in detail cuz we don't know the
Arabic language you know he would go in
detail the stuff she would have a little
back and forth agreements disagreements
as brothers what life there was never a
point our you just like we got some kind
infinite never we had discussions even
the brothers came from Birmingham Lucy
and down with them having discussions
back and forth having tea the [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to wait till the day I die
and insha'Allah if Allah accepts us to
his general to see you again
Allah he that's gonna be so painful well
that's gonna be so painful every time
off the speaker's corner me you thought
would bother Ibrahim the rest going how
I need to even bother Omar who recently
met him call me today he goes our comedy
Valley he goes that probably just met
him for hours and I know when people die
everybody says he was such an amazing
person to everyone and I'm sure they
were
but brother Issa was different while
live brother Issa you cannot replace
prophet ISA you cannot replace my for
ISA his smile but like you cannot
replace him he was someone that one like
I just looked forward to and I just I
need to just go to the park Pete he
would wait for me we'll go together jump
in the car eat together what would you
want where she would go today what are
you feeling Chinese Japanese tell me I
feel which way let's go there today are
there's this period
let's try this one why he it was a
preferred it was something that I
thought you know when I looked at my was
like what life anyone was to remind me
of the selleth it would be this guy if
there was anybody anyone to remind me of
good Adam good o'clock the one who
carries Islam within himself his
character not just the worst astronomer
that he give was this guy why why he I
will testify that Allah and Yama Yama
you alive I've come across that not bad
experiences but what lie when you have
sold like Esau that come and represent
the Dean in such a way with beauty with
kindness with softness but even non less
than people that had issues were calm
with it well I you know this brother was
special he was such a special brother
what like it's such a loss we miss him
so much one lie I miss him so much I
miss him so much what lie I cannot
describe to you guys how much I miss
this brother father says I'm not gonna
carry on I'm I'm so sorry the main focus
of this video brothers and sisters is
attributed at the same time we sell
reminder to us from the words he spoke
fathers and sisters the viruses were
lies aside from Allah our East above a
diamond is a sign from Allah he is in a
good place
he's with his Lord he's in a good place
but brothers and sisters were lying I'm
telling you guys what are you waiting
for
are you waiting till you die are you
waiting to them to make changes please
guys we need two things
22 things there's a fundraising page for
his daughter she is like our daughter
and well if anybody wants to come on
board we are going to take care of his
daughter like his house she's our
daughter like she's our daughter till
she reaches an age sixteen seventeen we
i if anybody wants to come aboard c'mon
tell me we're gonna make sure that his
daughter and his wife is taken care of
in every single way possible so we've
got a fundraising page for his daughter
and his wife and we've got a fundraising
page for tzedakah daddy for a life
finish that we're building the message
will be named under him after him the
school the playground and the water well
inshallah bhavan sisters if you can give
for that that's only one insha'Allah
Allah he was a beautiful soul
what a beautiful so
what a beautiful song that's all I'm
gonna say that's all I'm gonna say this
that's all I'm gonna say
may I laugh mercy on we all love mercy
and I'll testify he was a beautiful
Bravo
we all have mercy on you guys that's all
I'm gonna say I'm not gonna keep this
video long make to offer him and his
family all that his daughter
so he felt my note for a little bit soun
Genma I said I said I wanna come what
happens on a better care to take